thank you my pleasant job to present the
nominees in the category of actress in a
supporting role we're looking at five
women who range in age from none of your
business - how dare you ask which proves
that fine acting is a product of talent
not time the five nominees are Diane
Ladd and ramblin rose Juliette Lewis and
Cape Fear Kate Nelligan in the Prince of
Tyre Mercedes Ruehl in the Fisher King
Jessica Tandy fried green tomatoes and
the Oscar goes to Mercedes Ruehl the
Fisher King
oh thank you
hi I went to New York to study acting
the summer that I was 21 and like
thousands of actors before me and
thousands of actors after me I went
through the usual scores of moonlighting
jobs and usual scores of rejection and
usual legions of prophets of doom who
are always there and always at the ready
to give you the up to minute the odds
against your ever making anything of
yourself in this business and at this
moment all of those sort of doleful
memories has suddenly transform
themselves into nothing more than the
sort of charming and amusing anecdotes
from my memoirs
I cannot cannot thank you enough there
are a few people I'd like to thank with
all my heart very quickly the great
Terry Gilliam written yeah Richard
LaGravenese a screenwriter an
extraordinary cast it was an honor to
work with them Roger Pratt our
cinematographer Steve Randall Linda opes
Deborah Hill Howard Fuhrer Marcia
McManus my family and my close friends
for their patience and their respect and
their support and finally I would like
to thank Alberta nerado and the late
Joseph Papp who gave me my first shot on
the New York stage and my first break in
the big time and especially the late
great Joe Papp who once in a rehearsal
for that play nudged me out of the
shadow and into the light and told me to
stay there in no uncertain terms I have
I do I will thanks Joe thank you
you